ما هي ازمه سقف الديون بامريكا عام 2021
تم رفع حد سقف الديون ليصل الى 31 تريليون
دولار
ماذا يعني وضع سقف للديك يجب ان لا يزيد
اجمالي قروض الحكومه الامريكيه عن هذا
الحد سقف الديون هو اجراء وضعه الكونجرس
لاول مره في عام 1917 لتمويل الحرب
العالميه الاولى
الدين العام الامريكي بلغ واحدا وثلاثين
تريليونا وسبعمائه مليار دولار ما يعادل
130% من الناتج المحلي
الكونجرس هو من يحدد المبلغ المسموح
باستدانته الاستمرار في الانفاق على
الخدمات العموميه وفي حال فشل الكونجرس في
رفع سقف الدين ستضطر الحكومه لتحديد
اولويات الانفاق العامه الحكومه لن تكون
قادره على تمويل العجز في الموازنه
الاقتصاد الامريكي سيعاني حينها من زياده
كبيره في الفائده على السندات
خسائر فادحه ستواجهها اسواق المال
الامريكيه والعالميه والاقتصاد الامريكي
سيقع في فخر الركود تاخر الولايات المتحده
عن تسديد فواترها سيؤثر على توازن الدولار
وسيفقد سته ملايين وظائفهم وايضا رفع
مستوى البطاله لنحو تسعه في المئه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات